RETO MEIER: Hi.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
Developer Advocate.
Today I learned that every
car crash, 311 call, tree,
Citi Bike trip and station, and
limousine ride in New York City
is available as public data
sets in Google BigQuery.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Do you know on which
New York City streets
you're most likely to find
a loud party, maybe the one
place where a collision caused
by an animal also injured
a cyclist, or the Citi Bike
record for the longest distance
ridden in the shortest time?
One of the amazing things
about working at Google
is the ability to do whatever's
necessary to find answers.
So let's head to New
York-- or to this computer
representation of New York
from here in San Francisco.
After all, what
better way is there
to get to know New York City
than by immersing yourself
in the hustle and bustle of
data analysis and visualizations
representing its 8.5
million residents and 50
million yearly visitors?
For example, in 2016
these city streets
witnessed a lot of
traffic accidents.
There were over 200,000
motor vehicle collisions
across the five
boroughs, resulting
in over 50,000 injuries
and 200 deaths,
mainly due to driver
inattention and motorcyclists
being the most likely to die
in the case of a collision.
When the temperature
in New York drops,
New Yorkers retreat
inside and call 311
about the snow or lack
of heat and hot water,
especially in the Bronx.
All across New York,
people are concerned
with the noise and the
condition of the city streets.
But when you
normalize the results
by the size of each
borough's population,
you see that the
people of Staten Island
have the biggest
infrastructure issues.
No matter the weather, it's the
potholes, rough, cracked roads,
and cave-ins that have
Staten Islanders calling 311.
If it's a Wednesday,
the people of New York
are taking lots of short
rides on their Citi Bikes.
Since 2013, there's been over
33 million Citi Bike rides
averaging 15 minutes per ride.
Riders skew 76%
men to 24% women,
and with 52% of all riders
aged between 27 and 41,
with this route alongside the
Hudson by far the most popular.
Using these preloaded
public data sets,
you can investigate almost
every aspect of the city.
By analyzing tree survey data,
you can discover that, in 1995,
the most common tree in
New York was the Norway
maple with over 100,000
trees and that, by 2005, it
was overtaken by the
London planetree.
As always, your first
terabyte of processing
is free, meaning you can run
all the queries I've shown you
and many more at no cost.
Sign up or sign in
to BigQuery today
and create your own New
York City visualizations.
And share them with
us using this "today I
learned with BigQuery" hashtag.
And, of course,
subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog to learn
something new with BigQuery.